Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and today I'm breaking down the first full
official Avengers: Infinity War trailer for
easter eggs and other interesting details
you might have missed.
If you're new to my channel, I do regular
comic-book movie videos, and to celebrate
the Infinity War trailer finally dropping,
I'm kicking off a new superhero giveaway for
all my subscribers.
I've got full details on that plus the winners
of my Justice League giveaway later in this
video.
I'm gonna kick off with Bruce Banner because,
not only does his first shot in the trailer
give us a very cool easter egg, but also because
since Mark Ruffalo joined the MCU in the first
Avengers movie, he's given us the awesome
big-screen Banner and Hulk I've always wanted.
In the Infinity War trailer, we see Bruce
Banner back on Earth where it looks like he's
crashed through the ceiling of Doctor Strange's
Sanctum Sanctorum as the Hulk and smashed
through the floor.
It reminds me of Banner's crash-landing in
the Avengers movie when he met Harry Dean
Stanton's security guard.
This scene is a very cool nod to the first
issue of the Infinity Gauntlet comics in which
Silver Surfer crashes through the roof of
Doctor Strange's Sanctum Sanctorum to warn
of Thanos's impending arrival.
This is very likely also Banner arriving back
on Earth to warn the Avengers about Thanos
because, if you recall at the end of Thor:
Ragnarok, Hulk was with Thor when Thanos's
Sanctuary ship arrived to intercept the God
of Thunder's ship.
Also notice in this shot that Tony Stark is
holding a little phone and it looks like it
could be the same one that Cap had FedExed
to him at the end of Civil War.
Talking of Bruce Banner, we have an intriguing
shot later in the trailer of him in Wakanda
standing next to a huge Hulkbuster arm.
Later again we see the Hulkbuster, which looks
different than last time we saw it, and it's
in action in Wakanda; and it feels like there's
a hint here that we may see Bruce Banner getting
into the Hulkbuster for Infinity War rather
than Tony Stark.
There are other possibilities too, though,
and I wonder if it could be T'Challa's sister
Shuri in the suit?
We already know that Shuri is an engineering
and robotics expert with skills that are on
a par with Tony Stark.
Also, in that huge Wakandan battle, Hulk is
already there without any suit and I can't
see Shuri in that line-up.
And, on top of that, we've already seen an
important Wakandan character suit up in Black
Panther-style Hulkbuster armour in the comics.
Also, look a bit more closely at this amazing
line-up because Cap has some interesting arm
shields.
I think those could be some cool Wakandan
tech that's been designed for him.
And, of course, after Cap abandoned his shield
at the end of Civil War, I just loved Black
Panther's line, "get this man a shield", so
I wonder if that smart Wakandan tech could
make a shield materialise in a similar way
to how Black Panther's suit appears here.
Also, notice how Captain America no longer
has his star on his costume, which is understandable
given that, after the events of Civil War,
he's now a fugitive on the run.
That, plus Steve Roger's beard, symbolise
his changed role in the MCU and are a nod
to the comics where he took on a new identity
as Nomad when he took off his Captain America
costume after becoming disillusioned due to
the corruption of the US government.
As for his beard, that seems like a hat-tip
to Captain America's Castaway in Dimension
Z storyline in the comics.
There's also a very quick shot in the trailer
of Steve Rogers catching a spear from one
of Thanos's Black Order.
That figure, which we only get a glimpse of
here, is Proxima Midnight, who in the comics
was sent by Thanos to retrieve an infinity
gem.
And in the trailer, it looks like we see Proxima,
plus one of her Black Order comrades, Corvus
Glaive, attacking Vision's Mind Stone.
Like Cap, Black Widow is also sporting a new
look in Infinity War.
Her change from red hair to blonde is likely
because, like Cap, she's had to go underground
to lie low from the authorities.
When we last saw Natasha in Civil War, she
switched sides from Team Iron Man to help
Cap escape at Berlin airport, and Tony Stark
later warned her that the government would
be coming for her.
Now, I think we can all agree the Battle in
Wakanda looks pretty epic and is a huge hint
that Thanos is after something there, most
probably the Soul Stone.
And, if you're wondering what those four-armed
creatures are, well, they're Outriders.
In the comics, Outriders are genetically-engineered
beings used by Corvus Glaive and Thanos to
scout out worlds for tributes for the Mad
Titan.
The Outriders lack their own free will and
are essentially cannon fodder for their masters.
The trailer also reveals a battle in New York
with a huge portal-like ship or generator
appearing over New York.
And this is where we get an awesome shot of
Spider-Man, who's now wearing the Iron Spider
suit he turned down at the end of Spider-Man:
Homecoming.
Spidey seems to fail at stopping whatever
is going on here and gets a beating from Thanos,
but I wonder whether the next shot of Thor
in another huge circular object could be the
God of Thunder inside the heart of whatever
is driving this generator?
OK, let's look at Vision and Scarlet Witch
now.
We know already that Vision gets attacked
for his Mind Stone, but earlier we get to
see him together with Wanda and what's curious
is that we're seeing him for the first time
with a human face, although it looks like
he's still got the yellow Mind Stone in his
forehead.
I wonder if he has the ability to switch between
android and human form?
Also notice that Vision appears to be sharing
a room with Wanda, a big hint that we're seeing
their relationship progress from just cooking
Paprikash together to something a lot more
serious, another nod to how the couple also
got together in the comics.
By the way, a small thing I noticed is that
we never actually see Corvus Glaive extract
the Mind Stone from Vision, so I wonder whether
there's a chance the Black Order here could
be manipulating the Stone leaving it in Vision
and placing him under their control.
So, what about the other two stones we see
in Thanos's infinity gauntlet in the trailer?
Well, the blue stone will be the Space Stone
which we see Loki offering up to Thanos.
This scene very likely happens on board the
ship that Loki and Thor are on at the end
of Thor: Ragnarok and is strong confirmation
that Loki stole the Tesseract from Odin's
treasure room on Asgard at the end of that
movie.
You can see the carnage that Thanos has inflicted
on board the ship because these body markings
match those from Asgardians in the last Thor
film.
Although Loki is probably trying to save his
own skin here, I wonder whether there's a
chance he's offering up the stone to save
the remaining Asgardians as well?
And the purple stone that Thanos already has
will be the Power Stone which was given to
the Nova Corps for safekeeping by the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
There's a shot in the trailer of Thor looking
out over a planet which seems to be burning.
I think it could actually be Xandar, home
of the Nova Corps and therefore show the aftermath
of Thanos's attack.
So, in the trailer we have an idea of how
Thanos has got hold of three of the six Infinity
Stones he's after, but there's obviously three
more he has to get: the Reality Stone, the
Soul Stone and the Time Stone, and I may do
a video with details on where we can expect
to see those.
By the way, another cool detail you might
have missed is that the words spoken by Nick
Fury and the other Avengers at the start of
the trailer were actually originally spoken
by Nick Fury in the first Avengers movie.
"There was an idea, Stark knows this..."
"The idea was to bring together a group of
remarkable people to see if they could become
something more.
To see if they could work together when we
needed them to, to fight the battles that
we never could."
"There was an idea..."
"To bring together a group of remarkable people..."
"To see if we could become something more..."
"So when they needed us..."
"We could fight the battles..."
"That they never could."
And Marvel also sneakily includes those words
in their written form in the current Marvel
Studios intro.
So, did the Infinity War trailer live up to
your expectations?
And were there any other cool easter eggs
or details you spotted?
Make sure you leave a comment below about
the trailer and subscribe for a chance to
win a cool superhero Funko Pop.
The winners from my Justice League giveaway
are on screen right now and if that's you,
make sure you send me a private message with
your details so I can get the prize out to
you.
If you enjoyed this don't forget to hit that
like button, turn on notifications for all
my new videos, and check out some more of
my Marvel and other superhero videos right
here.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!